The joe rogan experience from that show
and then straight into hard to kill the
show for the discovery channel from going
then deployed to Africa like this year.
I don't even know.
I can't even,
how does that all work
while you're still serving?
Like how do you get the freedom to do
all these different things when you read
after you reenlisted. So the army
will always get with the army once,
um,
first of all,
but it's got to help them having you
be so high profile tentative of the
military. If you're listening right now,
go to your local recruiter. That's why.
But seriously, we are having
special forces specifically we are,
we are going to have the biggest
deficit of eligible up a pool,
a population to select from because
you have to have a certain level of
intelligence search,
certain level of physicality just to be
eligible for special forces to pick from
you. That pool is the smallest
that has ever been in history.
Why kids are playing video games.
They're not eating Cheetos,
they're less participation in sports.
I mean,
if you could just go to a high school,
it'll look at a high school are
now compared to 20 years ago.
It's a different thing.
Really. Yeah. We, we,
we weren't like barely getting
kids past obesity 20 years ago.
Now in a high school,
if you walk into a classroom,
half the kids are obese.
So you think this is just because they're
sedentary because of playing video
games and fucking around online all day.
It's not just,
it's not me thinking this is us.
Absolutely quantifiably saying we do
not have enough people to to pick from.
Right. And that would be one of the best
ways to really find out what the actual
average health of viable
males is. Right? Yeah,
for sure.
There's always going to be the best of
the best that want to test themselves.
I mean, this is just always how it's
been. So we teach hundreds of courses.
We only have that hundred,
we only get six or eight,
but that's a hundred people that
go to special forces selection.
That hundred that goes, they have
to have a GT score. They have to,
they have to have a scores high enough
on the military entrance exams just to be
eligible.
They have to have a PT score high enough
just to be eligible so we can't even
get that hundred and then of that hundred
only eight or the eight of them are
making it. So we're, we're, this
is, to answer your question,
how I'm able to do these things is I'm
in a position where I can say for the
love of God,
please get healthy.
Please walk to your recruiter's office
and please take a test to see if you're
eligible. Because we are just
needing people like we've
never needed them before.
Jesus Christ. It's scary. Wow. Well
that's one of the best indications.
I mean most people don't know,
like people like me,
I'm 50 year old father
taxpayer out there do much.
I'm not paying attention to what fucking
high school kids looking at it. I know.
I've no idea. Yeah, I do go to like a
marine recruiter right now and be like,
hey bro,
how's your job right now?
And there's a fight him from taking
that pen and stabbing it into his eye
because he just can't get
somebody that isn't smoking weed.
Somebody that can pass a PT test,
somebody that can pass the tape test
and it's somebody that can past what's a
tape test. I'm like, they're not.
So we measure their neck and their waist
and they can't even pass that so that
too fat. The two fat has the
neck too little or too big. Um,
so if you have a big neck, right,
and a big waste, this is, um,
cause like I have a big neck. Right,
but it's from working. Yeah. Yeah.
But I have a tiny little waist, so that
gives me my BMI and my body fat. You know,
they measure, it's, it's a pretty,
it's, it's a gross measurement, height,
weight and measurement.
Right. And the other,
there's only like four things that we
need for some, for us to say. Yeah.
It's harder to get into military
than it is to get in college. That's,
that's absolutely true. Not Regular
military, but special forest.
So regular military. Yeah.
Really? Yes. It is not easy.
And then from that we only
pick combat arms and then, oh,
that combat arms,
we only picked the top hundreds.
It harder for someone to get it to the
military than it is to get into college.
I thought it was fairly easy
to get into the military.
I'm pretty sure anybody can go to college.
Anybody. Well, you can go to community
college. That's college, right? Yeah. Um,
I'm not saying it's as easy
to get into MIT. Right.
But anybody can go to, some calls can go
to any college that they want, not any,
any color they can get in,
they can go to, you know,
local community college and then two
years there they can go and get into the
next unit.
You know,
like the state you school and then from
there they can get a right. I mean,
anybody can do that, right? Well, you
can't go to the military, be smoke weed.
You can't go to the military if you have
bad eyes, you can't go to the military.
If you're diabetic, you can't
go to the military. If you
have asthma, you can't go.
You can do, you can go to college if you
have all those things right. You know,
you, you can't go into the
military if your Iq is x
number, depending on your job,
well,
you can still go to college.
You can't go in the military if you can't
run a mile or two miles in this speed
and do this number of pushups
and this many of sit ups.
I don't think any college
has that requirement.
So I'm just in those seven things alone.
We just cry.
We just exed out 80% of our population.
And do you have,
is there also a problem with people's
attitude towards the military, um,
with young people? Yeah, a
little bit, but that, that,
that is mostly a physical issue
that is way less of an issue.
The perception of military is way
less of an issue than us just having a
qualified population of viable
candidates for us to pick from. I mean,
it's really bad where we're,
we're freaking, we were,
we were borderline freaking
out about what we're gonna do.
So an average special forces the ODA,
um,
has I supposed to have
12 guys in it? Right. Um,
right now you're not going to find
a team that has more than 10 and,
okay.
We only have 70% of our teams with 10.
Yes.
Yeah.
Thank God we didn't go to war with North
Korea if they got at war ended and that
we're not dropping nuclear bombs
on anybody because we're in,
we're in a hurt locker for qualified
to have no idea about this. No,
it's scary. Wow. So
this is my part of that.
One of the best ways to measure what's
wrong with the way people are living
today. Yeah. I mean,
forget about whether or not they
want to go and serve the, the,
the viable quality candidates like this.
A number of them that are even
available is the lowest it's ever been.
Well, what about high school athletics? I
mean, have they decreased, finished? Yeah.
Really? Yup. The same rate. The
party, very, very similar. Um,
the participation and not
so you can go and play,
um,
for your,
the rec time volleyball.
But to get onto the the varsity football
team or the varsity volleyball team or
the varsity track team,
the number of people in percentage to the,
so if you have a thousand people,
you had a hundred of them that were
picked to participate in those athletics.
All right. Should we at 10%, that
number now is down to like five or 6%.
So the,
the overall percentage per capita of
number of people participating in these
sports has been consistently
decreasing for the past 20 years.
Wow. 20 years in 20 years is essentially
when the Internet became a huge thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's basically the same timeline you're
looking at like 94 99 you see obesity
going like this. Yeah. Wow.
You got bad food. We got to opt to, our
jobs are getting less and less physical.
The, the focus on what jobs people
should have. Everybody's been like,
I'll go to college and you're like,
become an academic so you can be this
intellectual that can go and do this job.
And then you graduated from college with
a student loan and you have no job to
go to. Um, where there's
this guy that needs welders,
but it's not cool to be a water, so
don't, don't do that. Or to be a mechanic,
like all these trade jobs that are just
begging and pleading for and they are
sometimes physical, but they need people.
But it's not core to do that because,
you know,
like I want to go to and we'll go to long
beach state or I want to go to UCLA or
you know, I don't want, I want to go
hang out with a bunch of hot chicks. Lsu,
you know, it's, the focus has
been wrong for a while and uh,
and that is evident in special forces
selection when we don't have anybody to
pick from. We can't select. Wow,
why don't we hear about this?
Is it something that we're
trying to keep posher it,
it has been a problem
because our community motto
is the quiet professionals.
Mm. That's our motto. How
do you fit into that? Yeah,
I don't, I mean, I get so
much crap all the time. Um,
but thank God like guys that really
understand what I'm trying to do. They,
they realize I don't shut up because
I'm trying to help the regiment.
I'm trying the best ways that I can,
the best ways that we can figure out with
people way smarter than me helping me.
You know,
I was on the phone yesterday with some
of the best and brightest in the special
operations recruiting battalion
about how were we going to fix this?
How are we going to market? How are
we going to develop interest? And, um,
so thankfully they're smarter
than me. Um, but we were almost
screwing ourselves over because that is
what,
how we live. And that's how we would do
our job. If you read about us on the news,
we failed. You know, if you write about
army special forces doing something,
we met, we have done messed up you.
Now, this is not the navy seals.
We're not writing books. You know,
we're not talking about our exploits.
We didn't kill bin Ladin.
Um,
this is us just doing our work and
nobody's supposed to know about it.
But because of that,
we now have a huge recruiting problem.
Okay.